just got done working out cuz I can't be
fat I can't be fat during quarantine
don't be very you know is also not oh
we're gonna watch from cartoon hooligans
today Thor is not fat love this channel
I haven't seen one of their videos in a
while it just seemed like it'd be a fun
idea have you seen any of their videos
John seen at least one or two but uh
it's been a while
have you ever reacted to any of the
videos new there we go that's the answer
I was looking for make this an engaging
video right do being exciting geez he
could have lied Thor is fat don't you
know this Vic - YouTube - lying I've
never seen a Marvel made orphan
certainly no one my butt handed to me by
a Norse God
[Music]
[Music]
Hey aah
what is up nothing much by the way
you're back you're back you're back
you're back you're back
[Music]
just call me it's okay if you've gained
some weight Thor's gonna cut his fat out
[Music]
[Music]
it's my boys
it
[Music]
[Music]
it's pretty inspiring
how the dumbbells get bigger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hello gorgeous
[Music]
[Music]
you are going to love the dark music did
by the way
you're too buff - bah - bah - all for
the male gaze look at those muscles
really popping this is incredible
brother magical indeed
gay panic is afraid of afraid of his
homoerotic nature I know all that
attention boy oh boy that took a turn
yeah I kind of love its underlying
commentary that I think you can read
into if you'd like to you know yeah
that's a fair point of the dudes making
the most big fuss out of this being
perhaps for them I've read it in a
magazine not in a magazine or an article
on one of those magazine websites not
long ago that the preferred body tie
that woman now like generally speaking
it's all subjective I know
some prefer super buff some like a
little bit of cushion whatever
supposedly it's the dad bod okay now
Thor's going a little bit beyond the dad
dot in an end game obviously like he's
really let himself go but I've also
heard that a lot of women don't really
like the overly buff guy to what I
thought was funny about this was the
emotional abuse that the war indoors at
avengers headquarters and that really is
the odd man out the male body type is
glitter dad mainly for the the males to
look at and to admire fawn over this is
weirdly a cartoon parody that is
child-friendly that also has a
underlying commentary about body
dysmorphia and I have this like
sarcastic tone that I'm delivering it's
on display it is because like throughout
the whole thing the dudes are the most
like sensitive to him because you got
Iron Man Spider Man walking around the
front and iron man who does anything you
know you know Captain Marvel just comes
by to lays it out on the whole time
she's just like too fat you're too buff
it's really a whomp whomp version of
thor yeah and I love the confidence that
the were developed when he lost all that
weight you know I've been there you lose
a bunch of weight you'd realize it
you're like awesome and all confident
that endorphin boost and confidence
boost is temporary you know there's a
lot more internally within that you got
a deal with first and you're going out
there in the world putting yourself out
there with a woman or men depending on
who you know which way you swing this is
different than the other ones I've seen
because it had this like commentary to
it that maybe I'm reading too much into
it I think it's there
III think they were going a non-material
show there's some truth to be revealed
don't you kind of pick up what an idea
oh yeah I mean if I think back I mean
generally we are two dudes and we
traffic in a genre of entertainment that
has a lot of dudes in it but I feel like
dudes are usually the people I hear
talking the most yeah you know you'd
think that every time one of these
actors gets their photo revealed you
know you would have like a bunch of I'm
sure there are women who of course sexy
but yeah like the people making the most
deal out of it are almost always guys
and mics yeah I think there's definitely
some truth here and also some of that
too or they're like oh you were so cute
before the idea that like only this buff
Zeke is sexy or is something that you
could feel confident about is also just
like another little underlying theme
that I think is funny too I mean it's
funny cuz it's like Star Wars on in here
for the a long time I was just
attracting the commentary of women
telling me that they preferred Chris
Pratt of how he looked in Parks and
Recreation and how he doesn't guardians
of the galaxy but you can't win man you
just can't win overweight to buff like
what's the right middle ground fat buff
apparently cartoon hooligans has
something to say about the woman in the
Avengers world they're all judgmental
right those are our super heroine boy
don't worry someday you know what the
tables will really balance when we get a
plus-size female super yeah that's what
things will really start to shift around
we should have just left I guess so yeah
we need all this common fat this is
funny all right guys well what did you
think of this video subscribe to cartoon
hooligans if you haven't done so already
click tower notification Bell subscribe
to us it's the end of the month and with
mine we had patrons who are pledged to
our deleted takes in BTS rewards here
and that also includes a page in the day
name call app so let's shout out the
last bunch of people Marcus word Herman
Deonte W aka tongue punch heart box Abby
Smith Rutten R K Spencer
chase Gardner Lucas Romero I never know
how to properly end these thank you guys
so much for budget of our patreon page
hopefully you stick around for next
month once again make sure to subscribe